[Music]
I'm going to try to get through this
um thank you for what you did three
years ago
today um please tell me your thoughts um
on this third
[Music]
anniversary
I'm going to try to get through the show
today because what I see in MSNBC aner
cry it makes me cry
because January 8th 2024 Monday one week
from the first primary that's right the
Iowa caucus one week from today we shall
see oh I'm Dave Rubin this is the Rubin
report we're live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and locals share subscribe tap
that notification Bell if you have not
postgame show as always Ruben report.
locals.com and yes over the weekend it
was the anniversary of January 6th and
most of us survived we're doing okay
that is not what the show is really
about today today it is going to be an
extension of what we did on Friday our
show with Colin Wright and Andy no our
uh Friday recap of the week uh the de
thing is beginning to deie that's right
diversity equity and inclusion is
beginning to actually die enough people
are seeing it they are seeing the
indoctrination through how the system
has how the system how the marxists how
the activists how they've basically
subverted uh all of the good stuff that
this country was based upon and they've
brainwashed you could say at least a
generation but probably several
Generations but something at the
beginning of this year of 2024 something
really seems to be shifting and as I've
been saying over the last couple weeks
when we get some wins we can't just Pat
ourselves on the back and then just look
away we have to just keep going because
otherwise the culture of victimization
that we have all been part of for these
last couple years and we've as we've
watched all of our institutions collapse
all of our sens makers disappear all of
the goodness of America seemingly just
like Whittle away uh it will continue
unless we take some wins when we get
them uh so we're going to talk about all
of that and also how it's affecting even
some of the people on the right right
now because even when people on the
right get some wins they have a default
position to kind of go back and and do
things the wrong way so I want to start
today uh with a video of a former guest
of the ruin report multi-time guest uh
Dr Deborah so who is a sex researcher
she's been on the show many times she
was on Joe Rogan's show a couple days
ago and she was talking about that
famous or inFAMOUS depending on which
side of the aisle you're on I suppose
that famous Yuri bezmenov video that
we've shown you clips of multiple times
uh particularly over the last couple
months Yuri bov was a KGB agent for the
Soviet Union and he explains in this
video that we're also going to show you
a clip of that uh how ideological
subversion Works Dr so brought it up
with Joe Rogan I know you appreciate all
of the craziness that's been happening
in Academia in terms of the I watched um
Yuri bov I know you talk a lot about him
and the director and I feel like he must
be he must be psychic or something
because what he describes in terms of
ideological subversion and how to
control basically an entire Generation
by going through academics and teaching
them at a young age how to think what to
think more specifically and how to then
get people to a place where they can't
agree on what objective reality is
that's essentially what's happening on
University campus
so for myself having come through
Academia finishing my PhD realizing that
I wouldn't be able to stay there and do
legitimate research anymore um and so I
have to come on the well not I have to
come on the biggest podcast in the world
I'm very excited and grateful to be here
but I'm like why don't I just do my own
research and do it this way and not have
to be con constrained by a particular
way of thinking or knowing I have to
find certain things with my research in
order for it to be published and if it
does get published because and it goes
against what activists want want you to
say it's going to get pulled your funny
is going to get pulled you're going to
end up homeless anyway
so might might as well just go straight
from ad Tob the Yuri bezman off um
interview from I think it was 84 yeah um
is so crazy
because back then I'm sure people were
like come on this is nonsense this is
not but if you look at it now in 2023
like he was telling the truth he has to
have been telling the truth and that the
Soviet Union had planned this out for
generations and that they knew that this
was going to be a 10 20 30-year project
and it's been
successful Okay so we've shown you some
of those Yuri bezmenov Clips we're going
to show you another one in just a second
but the basic idea here that Dr so is
laying out that the
the the I the concept of how to take out
a country is not that complex if you can
get a whole bunch of young people if you
can get a generation to think that the
founding of the country was evil that
good is bad and bad is good not to know
their gender all all of the stuff that
we're constantly talking about right
that you could you could basically
subvert and destroy a country without
ever picking up a weapon now it's
interesting uh she said maybe he's
psychic which she was kind of joking
about but it's like it's not that he was
psychic it's not that he could see the
future he understood the methods the KGB
and that the Soviets were using in
America and have been using in America
now for at least three four decades um
interestingly I I just said to Phoenix
we we'll get her back on the show she's
been on a few times her own Awakening
related to all this because she was a
lefty uh back in the day she was doing
sex research and basically she was
seeing that there is a problem with all
of this trans stuff and that there is a
social contagion element to it and the
powers that be did not want her to
publish her uh stories and her research
so she had her own Awakening now let's
go to Yuri bezmenov himself and uh hear
a bit more on ideological subversion
ideological subversion that is a phrase
that uh I'm afraid some Americans don't
fully understand when uh the Soviets use
the phrase ideological subversion what
do they mean by ideological subversion
is is the slow process which we call
either ideological subversion or active
measures in the language of of the KGB
or psychological warfare what it
basically means is to change the
perception of reality of every
American to such an extent that despite
of the abundance of
information no one is able to come to
sensible
conclusions in the interest of Defending
themselves their families their
community and their
country it's a great brainwashing
uh process which goes very slow and it's
divided in in four basic
stages uh the first one being
demoralization it takes from 15 to 20
years to demoralize a nation why that
many years because this is the minimum
number of years which requires to
educate one generation of
students in the country of of of your
enemy exposed to the ideology of the
enemy in other words Marxism leninism
ideology is being pumped into the soft
heads of of of at least three
generations of American students without
being challenged or counterbalanced by
the basic values of americanism okay I
know we've shown you portions of that
before and we will continue show to show
you portions of it because it is
explaining what has happened in America
and what has led us to this very moment
right now this very moment which as I
said at the top of the show we are
starting to wake up to and a whole bunch
of people are now pushing back on but if
you take the basic ideas like America
isn't good and you teach that to a
generation uh that the country was
founded on racism and you teach that for
a generation or two that 2 plus 2
doesn't equal four and you teach that
for a while that having a penis has
nothing to do with being a boy and you
teach that for a while etc etc you could
see how you'd end up in a place where we
would be in this constant state of
Hysteria that we seem to be in but now I
want to connect all of that to how it
actually takes out the in institions now
of course we've spent a large part of
the last two weeks or so talking about
what's gone on at Harvard with the
plagiarism Scandal or the anti-Semitism
scandle and that basically everything at
Harvard is is fake and and pure BS in
essence but let's check another
institution so the Dallas Mavericks NBA
team the Dallas Mavericks owned by Mark
cubin we're going to talk about him in
just a moment uh they have fully allowed
diversity equity and inclusion uh into
their system it's something that Mark
Cuban believes in and his CEO who goes
by the name of Cynthia not goes by the
name her name is Cynthia Marshall I
suppose uh she is big on Dei and here is
a video of her explaining why uh and how
she believes in Dei and what they should
do about people who do not believe in
diversity equity and inclusion we want
to also focus on emotional safety and I
told the team uh these uh values would
be on the walls but more importantly
would operate in the halls and so then
we went through a series of uh sessions
to really dig into those values and what
it meant to have values based employment
at the Dallas Mavericks and then the 100
day plan was in four parts and it was to
model zero tolerance so set up a hotline
complaint process Etc do an
investigation Purge what we needed to
purge uh a Mavs women's agenda so a very
uh descriptive agenda around elevating
empowering and just educating women uh
cultural transformation which is all the
things around diversity and inclusion
Employee Engagement our employee
resource groups just the things we
needed to do uh to institutionalize an
inclusive culture um and then
operational effectiveness basic things
like market-based compensation
performance reviews gender pay Equity
analysis all that so it was about 200
initiatives w Lady there is a lot there
now remember this is the CEO of the
Dallas Mavericks her job is to make the
Dallas Mavericks basketball team as
functional as possible Right to win as
much as possible to make as much money
as possible to bring in the proper coach
proper GM have the entire structure
there so they have the best freaking
basketball team so they sell out every
game so they have everyone watching
bring on the best players sell in
jerseys etc etc everything she talked
about there had nothing to do with that
my friend Pete bosan who obviously has
been on the show many times he often
talks about this that once you allow
diversity equity and inclusion into any
company your eye is off the ball if your
job is to sell widgets and suddenly
you're deciding how many black sales
people you have and how many white
janitors you have you're not going to
sell as many widgets well now you see
that a as a institutionalized piece of
what's going on uh with the Dallas
Mavericks a couple things she talked
about there they're going to have a
series of sessions based on values based
employment so it has less to do with I
don't know the work that you do the that
you create it's going to be about their
values which of course have something to
do with race and racism they're going to
have zero tolerance I guess that means
if someone accidentally misgenders
somebody zero to and a hotline they also
have a hotline that you can call to
basically rat out your co-workers do we
have a hotline like that here there is a
hotline I've been uninformed about that
hotline um all right there's there's a
whole bunch more here but I want to
connect this to what's going on uh with
Mark Cuban which we'll do in just a sec
let me talk to you guys about Cozy Earth
you you guys all know the value of good
night's sleep we feel better look better
have energy to spare the list goes on
and on yet sleep never made my
resolution to-do list I guess because it
seemed like a lost cause I was either
too hot too cold too something that is
until I discovered cozy Earth beding
guys it's amazing I love using their
products here's why I love cozy Earth
bedding they were founded to transform
lives by offering the softest most
luxurious and responsibly sourced
bedding in the world the bedding is
ethically sourced using premium viscus
from highly sustainable bamboo and their
beds are naturally temperature
regulating and breathable so you sleep
more comfortably all year round cozy
Earth bedding comes with a 100 night
sleep trial which means you have up to
100 nights to sleep on them wash them
try them out if you're not completely in
love just return them within 100 days
for a full refund and all of their
products also include a 10-year warranty
against defects whether it's their
luxury beding Ultra comfortable
loungewear plush bath towels and more
make the New Year Cozier with cozy Earth
if you've never Tri tried cozy Earth
I've got some news for you you can save
up to 35% off cozy Earth right now but
hurry this offer won't last long go to
Cozy earth.com enter promo code Dave at
checkout for up to 35% off your first
order cozy earth.com promo code Dave
cozy earth.com promo code Dave trust me
I love this stuff you will too and now
back to me okay so now I want to connect
Yuri bezmenov the guy saying there has
been a plan to destabilize America and
here's how we're going to do it right
and what we now know what we call
diversity equity and inclusion is this
cultural Marxism that they've pushed
into all of our institution over decades
you have a former KGB agent saying it
right then you've got a sex re
researcher on Joe Rogan talking about it
you guys have been paying attention to
it on this show okay we understand all
that then we go to a place like uh
Dallas with the Dallas Mavericks NBA
basketball team supposed to be focused
on winning championships but mostly
focused on figuring out how many black
people will do this and white people
will do this and lesbians will'll do
that and all that Dallas Mavericks owned
by Mark cubin uh Elon Musk owns Twitter
he is not a fan of diversity equity and
inclusion I want to start this off by
showing you two tweets from Elon he
wrote this Dei is just another word for
racism shame on anyone who uses it yes
that's right and that's in reference to
a tweet by Bill Amman which I suspect
will'll talk a bit more about Bill Amman
throughout the week but let's just move
on to the next tweet from Elon he wrote
discrimination on the basis of race
which Dei does is literally the
definition of racism and of course that
is true there is no such thing as
Reverse Racism if you don't like white
people or you won't hire white people uh
in the name of Dei you are a racist
anyway those are two fairly obvious
statements that Elon Musk put out there
those are the ideas that this country
was founded on on equality and not being
racist that's how things used to work
but Mark hin who owns the Dallas
Mavericks who has allowed all of this
nonsense into his corporate institution
uh he tweeted back at Elon and he wrote
a bit of an essay here I'm going to try
to get you guys through it he wrote let
me help you out and give you my thoughts
on Dei number one diversity good
businesses look where others don't to
find the employees that will put your
business in the best possible position
to succeed you may not agree but I take
it as a given that there are people of
various races ethnicities orientation
Etc that are regularly excluded from
hiring consideration by extending our
our hiring search to include them we can
find people that are more qualified the
loss of Dei phobic companies is my gain
one a we live in a country with very
diverse demographics in this era where
Trust of businesses can be hard to come
by people tend to connect more easily to
people who are like them having a
Workforce that is diverse representative
of your stakeholders is good for
business two Equity treating people
equally does not mean mean treating them
the same I made the mistake for a lot of
years thinking it did Equity is a core
principle of business put your employees
in a position to succeed recognize their
differences and play to their strengths
wherever possible it is not a hard
concept but it is not easy to implement
most workforces don't have the depth of
management to do this well when it's not
done well it can create tension and
resentment three inclusion one of my
favorite sayings is that great employees
reduce the stress of those around them
great companies create great envir uh
create environments that reduce
unnecessary stress of their employees
I'm not talking hitting quota or getting
the product out of the door stress which
in turn increases productivity this is
what inclusion is all about making all
employees no matter who they are how
they see themselves feel comfortable in
their environment and able to do their
jobs again it's noty easy or why Dei is
like healthc care one of the lessons
I've learned in healthcare is that most
CEOs don't know and don't really want to
know where their health care benefit
dollars are going in their minds it's
not part of the core competency of their
business as a result they waste a
shitload of money on less than quality
care for their employees and more often
than not it's their sickest and lowest
paid employees that subsidize the
rebates and deductibles sicker employees
have to pay to their deductible healthy
don't so what does this have to do with
Dei like healthcare Dei is not seen as a
core competency in most companies it's
just a huge expense intellectually they
see the benefit of Dei but they don't
have time to focus on it so it turns
into a checkbox that they hope they
don't have to deal with beyond having HR
do a report to the board and legal tells
them they are covered don't worry I'm
almost there guys when anything that
impacts all of your employees is pretty
much a checklist item to the CEO there
is a good chance that it is not going to
work well and you are going to have
employees who are not comfortable for a
lot of different reasons which in turn
creates resentment towards Dei policies
and training which in turn makes it
harder on the managers trying to
implement it when companies do Dei well
you see you see a well-run successful
company so what's the conclusion if you
don't think there is a need for Dei and
it doesn't create a competitive
Advantage for your company just look at
the expost replies quotes below these
are the same people that work for you or
your co-worker everyone is entitled to
their point of view but these same
feelings even if they are not said out
loud are heard loud and clear at work
okay before I get into my response
Phoenix what did you call that when
someone gives you just like an essay
when you say something very simple and
they give you a long essay in response
what did you call thatal College that's
the liberal college girl response right
Elon Musk wrote like one he two tweets
there but like one liners and that is
just the long
ass explanation uh I responded to Mark
and I think I if I dare I say I whittel
it down fairly well to the problem of
what his essay was all about I said Mark
you are defining words in a way nobody
else does and certainly not how they put
them into practice he did respond he
wrote well we disagree there these are
things I do my best to put into practice
my point was that he it's not that he's
not putting what he's saying into
practice the point is that nobody else
is using Dei the way he's pretending to
Define it let's put it that way anyway
after his long diet tribe explaining his
version of Dei right we know it's not we
just heard from his own CEO at his
company talking about all the ways
they're using Dei um Elon responded and
I think he nailed it he wrote cool so
when should we expect to see a short
white/ Asian women on the Mavs uh which
is a good point because I don't think
there are any short white or and Andor
Asian women on the Dallas Mavericks Mark
cubin responded to that he said since
this seems to be the most common
response let me address it Dei does not
mean you don't hire on Merit of course
you hire on you hire on Merit diversity
means you expand the possible pool of
candidates as widely as you can once you
have identified the candidates you hire
the best person you believe is the best
what makes the whole what about the
players comment ridiculous is that it
presumes that all positions are hired
based on some quantitative rather than
subjective version of Merit they aren't
even choosing the best basketball player
is very much a guess which is why the
best players weren't always the first
pick in the draft and some go undrafted
the reality is that most positions hired
in a company don't have a quantitative
metric you can use to hire someone how
do you pick the best Barista sales
assistant marketing or salesperson Etc
God there's so much BS here more often
than not it's an educated guest so when
you see a company like IBM say they want
to add x% more people of color or women
or whatever group they already know that
the majority of positions they hire for
don't have metrics for picking best I
don't know how how Mark Cuban ever
created a successful company as Elon
Musk said if Merit for a job is roughly
the same than the tiebreaker should be
diversity of all kinds which is exactly
what well-managed companies choose to do
Dei also does not mean you can't fire
someone if you've made a mistake of
course you can I'm a big believer in
higher first higher slow fire fast it's
if it's the wrong person fire them
finally let me address the thought that
I'm virtue signaling I wrote this on X
because I knew very well that almost
everyone on here would disagree with me
I don't virtue signal I want people to
challenge my positions I want to have
engaging discussions that help me learn
uh he then uh put out all right so first
off you know I I know I'm being a little
snippy let's say with Mark cubin I just
think he he's completely
misunderstanding this but I I will give
credit where credit is due he did post
this on Twitter where he knows most
people are going to disagree with him I
don't really think he's well I can't say
I don't really think he's run his
companies like this because clearly he's
running the Dallas Mavericks like this
with the CEO over there but with all the
tech companies he has I don't know how
many companies he's in charge of or or
has put money towards like I don't think
that they've in the tech companies that
he's created let's say hired people with
any with thinking about diversity Equity
inclusion you you get the best
programmers and of course you do that
when we create locals were we looking at
their race or who they bang on the side
of course not it was like could you code
you think I care who these guys bang on
the side I don't care what you people
are doing all day I really don't as long
as you show up for work and you do a
good job and you smile every now and
again and and that's it tell me how
great I am anyway uh then Mark basically
completely blew up his own argument he
tweeted a link to
ESPN and uh it says Cuban would give
Griner a chance with Maverick Dallas
Mavericks owner mark cubin would be
willing to give Baylor women star
Britney Griner an opportunity to play on
the maps the problem is Britney grinder
would never make the Mavericks and it's
because she's a woman right we all know
that there's a reason that the WNBA
exists it's nice that girls like to play
basketball I went to high school I'm a
little bit older than her but I went to
the same high school as Sue bir she is
thought of as the greatest female
basketball player of all time I play
played a couple times with her in the
park and she was pretty damn good but
she wasn't better than most of the guys
and she could have never made it to the
NBA so if you if is it fair to say
Britney grinder is the best female
basketball player right now no who who's
the best terasi Diana terasi but she
retired right like Brianna Stewart
Brianna Stewart look at this guy he
knows God bless you for knowing the
names of several female basketball
players the point is nobody knows their
names and it's it's fine that girls like
basketball basketball I love
basketball and girls can like things
boys can like different it's it's all
good but Mark saying that and posting a
link to it yeah I'd give her a chance
well you'd give her a chance and she
would fail at it she is what do you tell
me
69205 something like that 69 205 so a 69
male basketball player you're usually
about 250 Jack huge you're a power
forward she would be crushed by these
people it's just the truth and we all
know it uh Ashley stclair she's an
actual journalist I think we have her on
the show later this week uh we've played
a couple things from her lately uh she
responded to Mark hubin and I thought
her response was quite clarifying she
wrote Dei is not seen as a core
competency in most companies it's just a
huge expense she's quoting him there uh
yes and any time you make something like
Dei a requirement it will turn into
checklists and eventually a lucrative
industry you give a pretty literal
breakdown of Dei from a definition
standpoint but seem to gloss over what
Dei and sister programs such as
affirmative action have become an
actuality which is ironically rather
discriminatory equity and equality are
also wrongly conflated here the reality
of Dei is destroying meritocracy to hire
based on race and gender for extra
social credit points and government
bucks this is wrong and will only breed
further division in this country that is
the point so again I I don't mean to
totally crap on Mark Cuban he's trying
to have a complex fight out in the open
and it is good to be able to debate
these things but it is fairly obvious
that when it comes to Bringing on the
best basketball players you can say I'm
going to bring on uh this black woman
but she will never make the team where
are the Asians on the Dallas Mavericks
the asian females so
Dei is bad actually I think we can say
it plainly it's bad because it is
morally wrong discrimination based on
race is wrong and it does not matter
which direction it goes in but there's
another reason it's wrong that I think
gets more to Yuri bov and everything
else we've been talking about here it's
wrong because it reduces the quality of
our outcomes in our products so when you
start thinking that that these
institutions aren't working and we're
teaching everyone the wrong thing and
products aren't as good as they used to
be and and I hear this from tons of
friends who own or run businesses that
you can't hire people anymore because
nobody knows anything nobody knows how
to do anything and work ethic has been
destroyed and you've had to hire these
people because oh my God that person
looked like that instead of hiring the
best person so Mark might maybe can be
one of the few people that can slightly
get that needle through there and make
it all work I suspect that he can't
again because of that very video that we
showed you of the of the CEO uh but when
you scale all of the wrong ideas across
a societal level then it reduces rces
the quality of life for a nation and
that is exactly where we are at right
now so let me give you a perfect example
of it what is happening right now right
this very second at what was thought of
as our most prestigious University in
the entire country Harvard well Harvard
is an absolute freefall because they
decided over the course of several
decades couple decades ago was they were
going to discriminate against Jews
because too many Jews were getting good
grades and working hard and caring about
family and all those things which are
deeply connected uh to living a
successful life and there were too many
quote unquote too many Jews at Harvard
so they had quotas against Jews then
what happened over the last decade or so
it moved on from Jews and they didn't
want Asians there right because too many
Asians were coming in this is in their
mind and they started discriminating
against Asians because they wanted more
black and brown students and you might
think okay but it's nice they wanted
more black and brown students that's not
mean but why would you discriminate
against an Asian kid who works hard that
is
racism okay so I want to flash to two
things that we showed you last week to
to bring this to tie this together uh
first off claudian gay has now resigned
obviously as president of Harvard she is
keeping her $900,000 job that's pretty
sweet when you resign uh she will be
teaching political science which is just
absolutely perfect uh but let's not
forget in her six-month tenure she was
applauded it was the media loved the
fact that they had hired this black
woman
who I'm told is not actually gay it's
just in her name but remember this this
is the this is the mainstream media
applauding this diversity hire Harvard
University making it history by naming
its first black president well for the
first time in history a black woman will
lead Harvard University some more good
news here as Stanford Alum and former
Professor has been named Harvard
University's first black president their
very first president of color she will
be the first person of color first
president of color Claudine gay will be
the first president of color and second
female president in the school's history
she's also only the second woman to hold
that position she will be the second
woman and the first black person to lead
the university she was born to Haitian
immigrants the daughter of Haitian
immigrants Professor gay is a widly
admire higher educated uh higher
education leader and recognized as an
highly influential expert on American
political participation Harvard has
always found a way to meet the
we have a long history of rising to meet
new challenges of converting this energy
into forces of renewal and reinvention
I'm clapping for her Washington Free
Beacon reporting that Harvard has
received a complaint as more plagiarism
accusations now emerge they're piling up
against the president claing gay this
according to the Washington Free Beacon
these instances of plagiarism were first
reported by the Washington Free Beacon
nearly 50 accusations of distinct
incidents of plagiarism and battled
president Claude Dean gay is set to
resign
imminently okay so you get the point
there right so the media six months ago
oh my God this is so incredible we got
this black woman it's so exciting right
no information about what her resume is
or anything else and then of course not
only do she have this this unbelievably
awful Congressional hearing where she
can't condemn whether you can call for
genocide of your Jewish students on
campus but then at at least 50 instances
of plagiarism so because Harvard
believed in Dei not only in the students
but also in the faculty and the
administrators all the way up to the
president they were hiring not the best
people I think it is fair to say that
claudian gay was not the best choice but
she was the Dei Choice uh let's not
forget how CNN covered it when uh she
got caught plagiarizing these plagiarism
allegations uh where claudon gay has had
to issue Corrections um multiple
Corrections now we should note that um
claudon gay has not been accused of
stealing anyone's ideas in any of her
writings uh she's been accused of sort
of more like copying uh other people's
writings without attribution so it's
been more sloppy attribution than
stealing anyone's ideas but I I had to
show you that one ago because it's just
one of the best she hasn't been accused
of stealing just copying it's the exact
same thing but that shows you so not
only did Harvard through Dei or Dei hire
somebody who should have not been hired
in the first place so that's the
educational institution but then we see
our media institution CNN running cover
for this ridiculous thing literally
running cover for a plagiarist and by
the way she plagiarized amongst many
things she plagiarized she plagiarized
from a black female scholar by the name
of Carol Swain who we should get on the
show um so okay you get it the end
result is that it brings Dei brings in
it ushers in a reduction in quality
uh in places like Harvard and in places
like CNN and basically anywhere that it
is instituted so once you hire based on
Dei once you look at a resume we we just
made a hire this weekend I did not do it
based on gender or on sexuality or on
skin color did
we no not that one the other one we no
you hire based on the best freaking
person it's as simple as that so of
course as you know what happened to uh
claudian gay well then she portrayed
herself as the victim tweet here from
Greg price breaking claudian gay just
published an oped in the New York Times
where she decries attacks on education
and expertise say says she fell into a
well-laid trap before Congress and says
that the people who called for her
firing traffic in lies and stereotypes
about about Black Talent so of course
she did all that like we knew that was
coming uh if you watch Friday show Colin
Wright who I had on he had predicted
that that was exactly what she was going
to do that she was going to be the
victim there was no well-laid trap in
the Congressional hearing all she had to
do was say oh you can't call for
genocide of Jewish students on campus
and she would have not been fired like
she would have been able to skate away
from this thing because she would have
used the Blackness the identity politics
it would have worked but she then got
the full storm of the genocide thing and
the plagiarism thing it was a bit much
anyway how else again how does this
destroy institutions we've watched
destroy Harvard we just showed you the
clip of CNN running cover this is a
beauty from the AP the Associated Press
Harvard president's resignation
highlights new conservative weapon
against colleges plagiarism yes and Klay
Travis uh my buddy he he tweeted that
out and he wrote I'm cautiously
optimistic that 2024 will lead to
widespread recognition among those with
functional brains that most journalists
in America are just left-wing
propagandists like really look at that
headline Harvard president's resignation
highlights new it's the conservative
weapon only conservatives would care
about plagiarism shouldn't we all care
about plagiarism and I will say once
again as I said on the show last week it
there is AI out there now where they can
start looking at everybody's
dissertations and papers and they can
try to match things up and they can do
it super quickly and easy if you show me
50 white male straight Rich Republican
College presidents well there are no
Republican College presidents but if you
show me a bunch of white guys who have
stolen a bunch of stuff and this can be
done very very easily then they all have
to be fired if we're to believe that
these institutions are are worth the the
paper that the degrees are printed on
and perhaps they aren't anyway more of
the media running cover here's Al
Sharpton a deflating he's a def the man
is deflating every time I look at him I
think he's deflating saying that
Claudine gay is mostly uh they're going
after her well because she's black she's
a woman blah blah blah gay is somehow
was to make up for the J historic of
blacks of women of gays OFA in asan and
since decided that he would stand up and
say that taking out Dr guy is beginning
of taking out
Dei I want to come to his office and let
him know that we will fight him we said
nothing the fight was in but now he's
the against all of
[Applause]
USI is something must have to equalize
the that's why we today Dei is something
we must have to equalize the playing
field no not in the things that I'm
going to be part of not in the way
America was set up to be not in the
things that will lead us to the future
if you want Dei now I get it Al Sharpton
you you are racist you have a long track
record of racist uh uh comments and
actions you're you're one of the biggest
race Hustlers uh in this entire country
um so if you want to keep running with
that then you will go ahead but we must
make Dei diie it is as simple as that
she would not be in trouble right now
had she not
plagiarized right are you saying that
the that they're going after her because
she's a black woman the media was nobody
had a problem with the president of
Harvard before any of this then it came
out that she's a plagiarist do black
people not care about plagiarism as I
said the woman stole from another black
scholar another black female
scholar lordy lordy but the point of all
of this guys is that when you take all
of these bad ideas that we've been
talking about and then you just
proliferate them throughout a society
then the good people the few good people
remaining you watching this right now
and the sane people who are out there we
all get pinned as the bad guys right Al
Sharpton would gladly call me a racist
he would gladly call you a racist and in
some ways that is what now the
overriding uh I would say thesis behind
the entire Democrat Party platform is if
you are either one of us you are either
an intersectional Dei wster or you are a
racist so now I want to show you a video
from over the weekend because it was the
third anniversary of January 6th and uh
here is the elderly man pretending to be
President Joe Biden and what is he doing
these days I thought he was the
president to come in and give us some
healing and we were going to get past
all the meanness with Trump and all that
stuff well here he is comparing Trump
and Trump supporters to Nazis he calls
those who Oppo oppose him
Vermin he talks about the blood of
America is being
poisoned echoing the same exact
language used the Nazi
Germany
Joe we can have some on Hest discussion
about some of the language and behavior
of Donald Trump I don't think I'm being
invited to maral Lago anytime soon right
I've been very critical of trump but you
can feel something happening right now
that Trump and Biden are just sort of
the mirror images of each other on one
you know in some respect that Biden is
just you're all racist and Trump is
you're all pedophiles I don't know
something like that that they are
basically building two campaigns we have
two parties building themselves around
you're the victim know you're I know
well I'm the victim I'm the victim
you're the victim you're the victim and
and we will never get out of this if
this is the best that we've got that is
the thing we will never if you think
that we have problems right now and we
do we will never get out of this unless
we start being honest about our history
honest about current events honest about
things that just happened so here's Joe
Biden a little bit more from that speech
about how we almost lost America on
January 6 January 6th might I remind you
where nobody brought weapon nobody had
plans if you broke the law fine and you
got to pay the price and if you broke
windows or you punched anybody or
anything like that okay fine but there
was no Insurrection in the idea that
there was anyone out there that was
about to topple the government but
here's Joe Biden we almost lost America
Today We Gather in a New Year some 246
years later just one day before January
6th a day forever shared in our memory
because it was on that day
that we nearly lost
America L that that language is insane
it's actually insane we didn't nearly
lose America it was wrapped up by the
end of the day right there were people
that were there were literally police
officers allowing people moving
barricades allowing people to wander in
I'm not defending every single person
that was there or what everyone's
intentions were or anything else but I
think you get it but what Biden needs
Biden needs all of his voters to to
think they're the victim my God those
white supremacist insurrectionists are
coming for us because that will Jin up
the base that will keep everybody
fearful and that will hopefully for him
get votes out and then lead to another
four years of this lunacy but I would
say the other version of that uh is
Trump so Trump has been campaigning in
Iowa over the last couple days here he
is calling on Biden to release the
January 6th what he refers to as
hostages uh something that he did not do
when he had the chance to do it what
they've done and they ought to you know
what they ought to do they ought to
release the j6 hostages they've suffered
enough they had to release
them I call them hostages some people
call them prisoners I call them hostages
release the j6 hostages Joe release them
Joe you can do it real easy Joe this guy
what he's done what he's done to
people okay as you know Donald Trump was
was President for 2 weeks after January
6th he could have done a little
something the president has pardoning
power he didn't Donald Trump we're also
told is a billionaire right they Donald
Trump is a very famous orange
billionaire how much money could we
Google this how much money has he put
towards legal funds of January 6 people
people give him a lot of money for
things has is it would it be a dime or a
nickel maybe 25 cents I don't think
anything someone can correct me on that
why didn't he fund some of that that
that might have been something he could
have do but anyway I'm trying to show
you that they're just sort of two sides
of the same coin right he's victimizing
himself and his supporters we need to
break out of this death spiral right so
we've got sort of the Dei left and the
victimized right that is not going to
solve any of the problems that we have
right now it simply will not but perhaps
there is a way perhaps there is a better
way and I mentioned at the top of the
show we are one week from today is the
Iowa caucus and maybe I know the polls
don't bear it out but maybe some of the
people maybe the Republicans of Iowa
will Iowa will decide to go in different
direction right because the definition
of insanity is doing the same thing over
and over and expecting a different
result and clearly at this point we are
not getting different results um but I
think maybe there's a chance for things
to be a little bit better here is an ad
that the disantis people put out just
over the
weekend we will break the cycle of
amnesty those days are over
[Music]
and yet today in remarkable twist the
president held a televised meeting with
the very swamp creatures he once
denounced he told them he trusted them
to craft immigration policy without his
input the White House proposal would
legalize about 2 million people who
currently have no right to be here
that's a lot of people a path to
citizenship for 1.8 million illegal
immigrants almost three times more
people
than the previous administration covered
then he suggested he'd be willing to
accept any deal they produced even a bad
one I will be signing it I'm not going
to say oh gee I want this or I want that
I'll be signing it and here's the part
that made Jeb Bush all warm and fuzzy it
should be a bill of Love truly should be
a bill of love very few of the
president's supporters voted for that
when they put him in office last year
and some of them are upset about it my
kids were born and raised in America we
have dreams too right-wing media like
Breitbart calling the president amnesty
Dawn you've given them more than they
could ever have expected from Barack
Obama Donald Trump ran on the premise
that America's borders ought to be real
that the repeated amnesties of the past
have betrayed voters and that this
country deserves an immigration policy
that looks out for American interests if
you are in the so-called establishment
Republican party this has been a great
stretch for you so what was the point of
running for president okay as you guys
know I don't have Trump derangement
syndrome I have interviewed the guy I
have been to maralago I am friends with
the kids I am not trying to be
heavy-handed here or anything else but
we have had nine years of this the
results are in most of the people Tucker
Carlson for God's sakes most of the
people that we just showed you there
analyzing what Trump was doing with
immigration and amnesty and everything
else those are people that love him
right that wasn't the lam stream media
or the fake news media or anything else
so why would you believe that Trump now
who's angrier who's turned against so
many people who will have trouble hiring
and all of those things that suddenly if
he becomes president again and by the
way he believes that the last election
was stolen so why wouldn't they just
steal it from him again that he would be
able to do all of those things better
perhaps there is a better choice for the
four and maybe even eight years Beyond
right this
moment you have never lost a political
race before in your career you are a
second in the CBS Iowa projections um is
that Victory enough for you well we got
to win a majority of the delegates this
is a long process we're doing really
well in Iowa you know I kind of like
being underestimated Margaret so I hope
people kind of say say that uh but we've
got the enthusiasm when the calendar
clicked to 24 you see we got more
undecided voters coming out to all our
events so we're going to outwork
everybody but this is a long process uh
there's a lot that happens to accumulate
all these delegates we're going to do
well in Iowa but we're also going to be
competing in all these other states uh
and I think that there's a lot of real
estate I think a lot of things are going
to happen I wish the former president
would actually debate though I mean I
think if you're going to stand for
nomination you should be able to stand
on a stage to do it I'm happy to debate
him on your program or if your network
wants to host a debate in New Hampshire
South Carolina uh but the idea that he
can go and just read off the
teleprompter uh for 45 minutes and then
go back you know back home that doesn't
cut it in Iowa and that doesn't cut it
in a lot of these states and so uh let's
go get on the stage and let's have the
the debate of ideas and I hope Donald
Trump will be willing to do that all
right guys so look I know you know this
but it is fairly obvious to me which
direction let's say first the Republican
party has to go before the country can
go if we are going to fix this from a
political level right there's a guy with
a track record who does what he says
he's going to do then moves on to new
things who doesn't have all the drama
around him and everything else like
there there it is right there now we are
one week from that caucus and you know I
have a lot of people tweeting at me all
the time going Dave don't you see the
polls why you're going down with the
ship with this thing you know I believe
that fighting for the right thing is the
right thing to do no matter what you
know when we were in California and
there was the recall against Gavin
Newsome there was virtually no chance
that he was going to you know he was
recalled and then there was an election
but there was virtually no chance in a
in a one- party state that California is
uh that Gavin Newsome was not going to
win the recall election
but I wanted to give everything I had to
Larry Elder because you can wake up
enough people now I do believe that
Ronda santz has a chance and I do
believe that people are going to be
shocked uh next week one week from today
but maybe not maybe not but that doesn't
mean that you don't fight for what is
right so the right speaking of the right
the right has to make a decision which
way do you want to go is this just going
to be about cult of personality and the
culture wars and the gotcha moments and
all of that stuff or will we make a
better choice and and we shall see which
way we go it's kind of funny if you
think about it that this is left to just
like a couple hundred thousand people in
Iowa to really set this thing off is is
sort of interesting if you're watching
this in Iowa I hope you realize you have
an awful lot of power uh at least for
the next little bit but it's not just on
the right we can't just first off this
is not something that can just be fixed
politically but it's not just something
that can be fixed through the Republican
Party the Democrats are going to have to
get better too right we know that the
inmates are running the Asylum with the
Democrats you've got a guy with dementia
running the party you have Hamas
activists literally in the party AOC and
Rashida Talib and ilhan Omar and the
rest of them uh but even that thing
people are seeing through that too uh
let's not forget Robert F Kennedy Jr
Kennedy Kennedy the name which is most
synonymous with the Democrat Party more
than any other name he left the
Democrats because of the radicalism uh
and I saw this video over the weekend
and I thought this was really
interesting if you are frustrated if
you're looking at the election right now
and you're going boy I really don't like
Joe Biden and I don't even think he's in
charge and I can see all the problems
America has kind of over the Trump thing
don't really like that don't like all
the drama he's not even campaigning
won't debate I've kind of had it with
that is there another choice if the if
these are the two we're left with right
if the disantis thing just doesn't work
out these are the two we we are left
with is there another Choice well RFK
actually mapped out uh a possibility and
what his shot could be these are
Battleground States among young people
voters 18 to 29
and this is a combination of the main
Battleground States Arizona Georgia
Michigan Nevada P Pennsylvania Wisconsin
um Trump at 29 Biden at 30 you are at
34% and then voters 30 to to 44 years
old you beat Trump and Biden at 31% but
let me ask you this in you have to have
270 electoral votes can anyone get to
270 if you were to have this kind of
this kind of margin in the real in the
real situation we're very confident that
we're going to get to 270 votes as you
point out President Biden president
Trump get on the ballot for free they're
going to force us to spend $15 million
to get on the ballot I only need 34
points to win the election because in
technically I could win with 34 points
if the other two got 33 and win or take
all and that's how I'm going to win I
have 10 months to take 4.5 percentage
points from both candidates and we're
very confident that I'm going to do that
okay as you guys know first off I fully
put it out there it is a very very long
shot that a guy like RFK and an
independent could win even despite his
name and everything else you also know
that I have some political disagreements
with him he was for the affirmative
action uh he's for he is for affirmative
action he was against the Supreme Court
reversing it we got into it we discussed
it on the show he's definitely more big
government than I am but I know this guy
really loves America I also saw an
interview with him a couple days ago
talking about all of his libertarian
beliefs like he he is a good de American
that wants to get us past all of the BS
um so maybe there is some other way I
think that a whole bunch of people I if
you just look at those numbers right
there if you just look at those numbers
basically people under 44 like him just
as much as they like those other guys
people don't like the choices that we
have so it's going to be an interesting
week we got an interesting week coming
up and then we got an interesting couple
weeks after that where this this will
start getting sorted out um but the
point of all of this the the point of
the show on this Monday is is that we
have been ideologically conditioned for
the past 10 years to think that really
at this point only our choices are only
Trump or some sort of racial woke mind
muddled Democrat those are the choices
we've been given at a national level
between the Republicans and the
Democrats we must break this cycle
because this cycle is leading us to
societal collapse it actually is and
guess what there was a guy who did a
video about 40 years ago explaining how
another country was trying to infiltrate
us to create societal collapse his his
name is Yuri bezmenov have I shown you a
video of him let's try it again
ideological subversion that is a phrase
that uh I'm afraid some Americans don't
fully understand when uh the Soviets use
the phrase ideological subversion what
do they mean by ideological subversion
is is the slow process which we call
either ideological subversion or active
measures AC in the language of of the
KGB or psychological warfare what it
basically means is to change the
perception of reality of every
American to such an extent that despite
of the abundance of
information no one is able to come to
sensible conclusions in the interest of
Defending themselves their families
their community and their
country it's a great
brainwashing uh process which goes very
slow and it's divided in in four basic
stages uh the first one being
demoralization it takes from 15 to 20
years to demoralize a nation why that
many years because this is the minimum
number of years which requires to
educate one generation of students in
the country of of of your enemy exposed
to the ideology of the enemy in other
words Marxism leninism ideology is being
pumped into the soft heads of of of at
least three generations of American
students without being challenged or
counterbalanced by the basic values of
americanism should we show you that clip
one more time today did we lay it on
thick enough for you I think you got it
I think you got it so how about we me
you person watching this how about we
take some active measures right that's
one of the phrases he use he uses how
about we take some active measures to
change the perception of reality instead
of letting them do it to us how about we
start doing that and we start standing
up for what we believe in and we start
voting for different people and
supporting good people it does not have
to be this way it doesn't have to be
Trump vers Biden it doesn't have to be
that all of our institutions will
collapse and America will fail and all
of those things but we got to get a
backbone like a ramrod and if we do I
think we can fix this thing that is a
fine MonDay program for the People
speaking of the people we are live
people of the internet at 1 pm today uh
if you want to join us for the postgame
show momentarily Ruben report.
locals.com what do we do for Mee Monday
today let's see what we got for Mee
Monday do
we that's some fine work you're doing
over there Brock you're you're getting
lunch today uh that video believe it or
not is now our number one meme that
we've ever shared on Instagram 60
million views for pushing that trippled
man out of a
wheelchair 2.1 million likes what a
world anyway we leave you with the
diversity hire that is now Vice
President postgame momentarily ciao you
think you just fell out of a coconut
tree you exist in the cont
context of all in which you live and
what came before
[Music]
you